I've been talking for years about
cultural fit but you know fit can be
sometimes very passive and I like to
think now more about cultural Contra
contribution which is if someone fits
our values if they believe what we
believe we want them to take our values
and go and and and build upon them we
want them to go make things based on our
values help contribute to the culture
make it grow now one of the ways you
hold people accountable to values is you
know recognition and reward you you get
the behavior you reward
I did some work with the the Navy Seals
uh the director of training for that
group drew a graph for me you know uh
performance and trust and what they
learned was that the high performer of
low trust is a toxic team member and
they would rather have a medium
performer sometimes even a low performer
of high trust than that high trust than
the high performer of low trust and if
you think about business we have a
million metrics to measure someone's
performance and we have negligible to no
metrics to measure someone's
trustworthiness and the irony is trust
is actually a very easy thing to measure
go to any team ask them who the
is and they'll all point to the same
person you know and by the way likewise
if you go to any team and you ask them
who has your back always they'll also
point to the same person which is your
best natural leader that may not be your
your best individual performer and so it
raises the question are we putting the
right people in leadership positions
because those people are more likely to
engender trust and and perpetuate the
values I mean I think we we forget that
you know we're human and you know the
way we track metrics the way we measure
each other is is if we're machines now
those you know output is very important
but input is really important too and
it's just harder to measure you know
like we talked about trustworthiness and
cultural contribution and you know
creativity these are things that are in
all of us but we don't know how to
measure them easily and objectively in
the short term it also reminds me of my
favorite definition of humility
um Bob Gaylord who's the fifth chief
Master Sergeant of the Air Force said
don't confuse humility with meekness
humility is being open to the ideas of
others and I've met some pretty
remarkable powerful uh people and
Leadership positions who absolutely have
big egos but they're still open to ideas
of others a healthy ego is thinking
you're good an unhealthy healthy ego is
thinking that you're better than
everyone else